so good morning everybody first of all
on behalf of all again myself thanks for
the invitation to speak here this
morning so I think by way of
introduction let me start off with you
know why is there a healthcare related
talk or why is there somebody from
healthcare and and why us so I do a
couple things at geisinger one is I'm a
clinical neurosurgeon so I practice
still practice medicine I see patients I
operate on patients with brain and spine
tumors number two is I'm our
organizations chief data officer which
is primarily a strategic position for us
that that involves coordinating how we
use our data resources and how we
develop our infrastructure and our
people to help extract the maximum value
from from our data and geisinger is a
place that has a lot of data we adopted
an electronic medical record about 20
years ago now so we're sitting on 20
years worth of EMR data so we've had
quite a bit of information and it's
always been part of guys ingress culture
to try to use that information and so
data is part of what we do and has been
for a long time and then number three is
I had our data science department which
is largely an R&D type department and
that's primarily the hat that I'm
wearing and we're wearing today Oleg
Roderick is one of the data scientists
in our department and it's interesting
because if you think about data science
in healthcare you probably think of it
as a relatively immature field compared
to a variety of other places doctors in
particular are not well known for their
statistical prowess and other such
things or ability to understand complex
math and so many healthcare data
scientists are largely focused on fairly
simple optimization problems or you know
essentially simple predictive analytics
that kind of thing we're trying to take
a different spin on that and look at
some of the fundamental problems or
fundamental challenges associated with
data and with how we use it and how we
make predictions from it and how we
apply it in our case to the point of
delivery of patient care but really our
data science department takes some folks
who came from anywhere but healthcare
and brings their mathematical
computational statistical engineering
skills to bear on some of the
fundamental questions that allow us to
do all the things we do with healthcare
data better and so that's what so that's
where we come from and why we're giving
this this time
today and the topic is something that's
particular interest to me into our group
and has been for a while which is the
whole idea of dirty data and and what it
is and how we use it and and can it be
used in to what extent and how do we
know so just by way of disclosure
because of course our academic I do some
consulting if you google me you'll see
that this has nothing to do with that
this is a guy's in your talk so that's
fine I only have one Twitter handle
though so if you feel so inclined as to
live tweet this because it's so amazing
at nine o'clock in the morning there you
go you can use that one so health care
what's interesting about health care and
data and why it's a good place to do
this kind of work is that we have a lot
of different kinds of information so
there are a lot of sectors that deal
with bigger data sets that we have there
are a lot of people with terabytes and
terabytes of sensor data and other such
things but Health Care's got
circumscribed amounts of many many
different kinds of information and it
comes from a very practical setting we
get it from from patients we get it from
from patient-reported data we get it
from lots of imperfect measures of
collecting things we get it filtered
through the eyes of doctors and nurses
and so it also happens to be noisy data
dirty data skewed data basically any way
you can screw up a data set we've
managed to find a way to do it in
healthcare right and that's good because
it's a great place to learn how to deal
with data that has those problems and so
I think we have a real opportunity in
the area of data related challenges to
be leaders in the space of what we do
with these things so we ask the
fundamental question what is dirty data
and I think everybody has heard someone
sort someone say in a relatively fickle
fashion well garbage in garbage out you
know and so if you don't have high
quality data you're not going to have
high quality results and of course I
agree with that you can't make good
predictions off of bad numbers the
problem is how good are we at
recognizing what are bad numbers and
what is really dirty data and what data
prohibits us from drawing certain
conclusions and what data may have
problems in the data set but doesn't
actually prohibit us from asking the
kind of question or answering the kind
of question that we want to answer so we
think about where does this dirty data
come from well like I said we have it
filtered through lots of different eyes
lots of
different systems and so we've got a lot
of opportunities for looking at skewed
data and data that has you know noise
related problems a low signal-to-noise
ratio missing data sparse data rare
events type predictions right this is
the world that we live in and why do we
care it's because in healthcare as in
many fields it's relatively expensive to
get the data in terms of the resources
that are consumed to extract it from
from patients you know the doctors time
the nurses time the diagnostic
modalities the patients have to come in
this sort of thing it's not easy to
gather and so we want to make sure we're
making the most out of the information
that we have and I think to just say
well garbage in garbage out this data
said as far as I can't do anything with
it and throw it away oftentimes takes
you know takes a potentially valuable
data set and the potentially valuable
data resource and causes us to summarily
dismiss it when that's really not
necessary and in fact relatively
imprudent but the question of course is
trying to decide what do we do with that
data that when you take a superficial
look at it looks dirty right so do we
try to clean it do we spend a lot of
time filling in the gaps do we spend a
lot of time looking for erroneous
results and tweaking them just a little
bit to make sure that those numbers are
spot-on correct certainly I know people
who argue that this is the thing to do
and I've worked with some folks who have
taken this to the extreme to the to the
extent where they almost can't sit down
or won't sit down and try to write a
predictive algorithm until they're one
hundred percent certain that every cell
every field every table is complete as
thorough is accurate and then they move
on to the next phase the problem is
sometimes it takes them years to get to
the point where they're willing to move
on to the next phase and that's not so
helpful either so I tend to take perhaps
the extreme opposite view which is to
say let's start with the information
that we have and let's try to learn what
we can ask reliably about it and if we
understand what we can ask and what we
can't and in what ways the errors that
we find in this specific data set affect
the kind of questions that we're asking
downstream as long as we know what to
expect we can say with some degree of
certainty yes this is the kind of
question that I can ask if this data set
and still get a reasonable answer even
though there's air in it or no this is
not the kind of question I can ask of
this because it's just so flawed in a
way that is so important to asking the
question that we can't trust what comes
out or this is a data set that's pretty
close and if I make a small investment
of time and effort in cleaning focal
things about it the quality of my answer
will get much better so I think to just
say oh it's dirty data forget about it
garbage in garbage out dismisses an
awful lot of the potential that we have
with a lot of real-world data now of
course the question is how do we know
what's the difference and how do we
figure out those pieces in the middle
and so I think sometimes it's reasonable
to accept it and I think the question of
course is figuring out how so at this
point I'm going to turn it over to Oleg
Roderick because my lead data scientist
in our group and he's going to talk a
little bit more about the nuts and bolts
of how we've chosen to approach this
question and some ways that we're
thinking about studying the consequences
of what we call the consequences of
decisions about data so by looking at a
data set understanding the kind of error
that it has and then perturbing it in
certain ways and looking house looking
at how certain things change trying to
get a sense of what kind of questions we
can reliably answer and what kind of
questions we can't and how much those
little changes that we might make in the
data set can improve the quality of our
prediction so my job is to frame the
question and then to turn it over to
somebody who's way better at math than I
am to tell you how we actually answer
the question and so with that dr. Rutter
so do I need to do anything to turn this
on now excellent so thank you all for
being here let me say if you were to
show you about 10 pictures the tone of
the conversation is going to change a
little bit because I have way more
arrows and but I'm trying to be a little
bit more specific so so Nick has already
said we're doing with the data as it
comes from multiple sources so very
different size and integrity this is a
picture that I'm not particularly proud
of because it's very approximate but it
gives you an idea that some information
we know about our patients in extreme
detail and we know for almost one
hundred percent like we know what
everybody is called for now what
everybody's ages are at the same time
the lab results somebody might not have
a lot of lab results somebody might not
have results reported in a particular
way that were interested in the database
so we have at least nine different
sources of information that come with
different
both of integrity oh that is a lot of
varieties that stands and confuses
people on the other hand the analytics
protocol is fairly straightforward we
have a person with the medical
information in the 21st century as a
walking into the hospital before it as a
doctor even gets the season we should in
principle already know the likelihood of
different events happening to them what
are the risks what are the resource
allocations do we need to allocate
particular medical personnel time then
we need to turn on expensive equipment
fortunately for us as humans people
don't have complicated medical histories
we don't have a patient that had ten
different kinds of heart attacks so we
cannot extrapolate from the past history
of a patient we need to connect it with
other people's information that is
extremely diverse extremely damaged but
fortunately for us high-dimensional we
take individual a patient's history of a
related to cool in case history for
revelation of patients that first arrow
there is where all the damage is
actually hidden because once we have
pulled data and aggregated as a training
data we accepting it as gospel truth and
if a better result comes out well you
can blame ser ethically that somebody
who did something role in the beginning
we suggest to move one step further and
attach that blame quantitatively and do
something about that blame in an ideal
situation everybody who wants to do the
data driven study in healthcare should
have some sort of a process of ingesting
data into the model we decided to give
the test to the first year computer
science student because we wanted to
keep it very straightforward and simple
and so we worked with him for a couple
weeks and then now we're giving the test
to slightly more advanced people but the
idea is very straightforward if you read
data find out for every item of data
what it is we wrote a set of simple
scripts that read numbers if their
numbers they keep intimus numbers if
they damaged missing entries they using
imputation techniques now this is the
important part every time an imputation
technique is called the records the
reliability of that imputation technique
solves it in the end when we have a
fixed table with no gaps on it
we'll have another table next to it
identifying which data is actually real
and which data was recovered and design
different levels of fidelity how to
assign level of fidelity that is another
question what's important in this talk
is it now we have a placeholder for the
importance of a particular data point
and keep going if it's not numerical
data at all we need to convert it
somehow need to have a conversion
process the simplest conversion process
is build a dictionary in on monday is
equal to one tuesday is equal to two who
said that this is the best assignment of
numbers no one did i am trying to bring
this up to the following conclusion both
damage in the data and operations we
perform on data in the normal course of
preparation changed somehow you can in
fact damage data in an attempt to
interpret it and fix it let's treat all
the operations maiden data as the same
kind of operation who are not really
fixing data we're not really a damaging
data we're just changing it and let's
trace the consequences of those changes
developing that same idea what if the
data is not numeric of symbolic at all
whatever its images or a narrative
written by a doctor's that would
typically be a PDF file with some
keywords in it or a real-time vitals
data you know at resolution of 10 times
per second nobody is plugging that into
statistical models they should have some
intermediate step some sort of external
tool that converts dance data source two
numbers record reliability of that
conversion and propagates a reliable it
is throughout your whole model and in
the next picture I'm trying to see her
in principle how it would be done on the
right in blue and gray you have the
process as it's happening right now
rotate is becoming transform data it
gets put in the statistical technique we
have announced results on the left in
green we have something it needs to be
built on top of that and the elements of
that are take the data in the
transformation take all your
dictionaries and all your notes of
reliability unreliability note on
reliability is essentially a measure of
variation of this particular data point
you think there is number 5 written
there but it's actually plus minus two
so treat that that as a stochastic
variable and
use is analytical a sampling technique
make all the possible changes to data a
uniform our computers are pretty big
right now and unlike humans computers
don't get bored you can ask a computer
to run ten to the sixth surgical
scenarios or what else your data could
be the trade-off here is that we cannot
afford to have a very complicated
predictive model that sing in the lower
right corner that could be a fairly
sophisticated adaptive technique maybe
with some human decision made in the
middle but cannot determine a set so
we're not instead we have a simplified
predictive models at services
placeholder it could be something as
simple as a linear regression model we
don't know what you as an analyst one to
do with your data so we're not going to
guess we're going to do something very
very basic put your data through a
linear regression model and see how
damage in your data influences output
make it more complicated put it to some
sort of transform linear regression or
logistic regression find out what is
happening in the outlet in the very end
you have some analysis results versus
hypothetical analysis results due to
damage in the data and attempts to fix
it you compare the two measures of
variation if you like the variation if
it's small enough don't clean the data
it's good enough if you make tiny little
changes to data and the results of
hypothetical analysis i becoming hugely
varied that data is maybe not extremely
explained important but it is extremely
sensitive if you need to make efforts to
fix it zas for the first time at least
in healthcare field we have a
quantitative approach to figuring out
how to prioritize efforts and clean the
data this is an ID n process it's not
completely finished now if you read
literature including data you'll see
that people are obviously getting paid
per page there are taxonomies of damage
done to data that run in two to three
hundreds especially with financial data
there are so many different ways in
which a payment could be reported wrong
and they get why they need it but we're
going into as a direction we are trying
to simplify it extremely this is our
simplest taxonomy and we if we can cross
out one part Volvo gladly do that
because those are all the different five
scenes that can happen to data represent
the table
transformation you remove a feature you
add additional data you remove
additional data you recover missing
entries and then you just introduce
numerical perturbation that could be due
to you trying to fix the data or it
could be present ins data already number
six is a little bit unusual this is our
first step in moving from the tabular
format to actual relational databases
that's when a relational link is
established as the data a simple example
would be suppose we have four entries
you want them to always add up to one
hundred percent people who use Excel to
engineering calculation should be very
comfortable for that kind of thing that
is also a deterministic st. happens in
the data with the help of that you could
start asking very unusual questions for
example we run a study on our population
of 3 million patients we come to some
conclusions as about thirty to fifty
percent of publications and medicine
it's very hard to reproduce because it
will never show you our data we will not
show you all but there is no reason for
us to so we can ask the following
question how can somebody reproduce the
results of our study without having
access to our full data well don't give
them our full data scramble the data
make some features anonymized remove
some features and use some fishes as
placeholders for other features like we
are not giving you the extra physical
addresses of our patients but we could
tell you how far away they live from
each other abstractly that is a set of
basic operations we can actually with
the help of the tube we propose to
develop and so formally the following
question what is the maximum damage done
to the outcome of your study given that
you have performed this an immunization
on the data from the point of view of
the user we're thinking of a user
interface and we rejected that idea
there is no reason to have a pretty
picture on the screen because the data
will probably be too big and too complex
to fit in the same screen so right now
what we are considering is some sort of
acquiring language that will allow the
user some conditional statements so he
could fill out that additional matrix I
was talking about in my first slide next
to the data you have a map of supposedly
reliable
of your data and then the usable answer
simple questions like what parts of the
data are compromised or suspected to be
compromised and what are the allowable
operations we do to fix the data and
then we do one of the two things either
we just do those operations do a million
of them or 10 million how much we can
actually budget it to the computational
power available if you are not happy
with that and that's a very appropriate
slide to have a fall from dat assignment
we need our system to act as a computer
algebra system allocate variables for
training data are training data labels
parameters testing data testing data
labels error and projected results due
to dimensions of data and just propagate
the damage in the data store all the
deterministic steps it might not be
pretty but a mathematical tools are
completely prepared for that people
already do it in engineering
calculations at a fairly simple let's do
it in our more abstract way data science
calculations this is this is a fish
because we decided that abbreviation of
consequences of decisions made and data
should have an angry fish in it god mad
that's all well that's what we have
instead of sense of humor I am sorry
about that actually I am it is a work in
progress right now we have a set of
poison libraries on to which we are
going to be adding features also the
next year what it can do right now is
take your data take your matrix of flags
that will identify the data is
unreliable completely missing and do
different types of imputations for
example we have a few basic operations
like that we are not up to fully
integrating everything else did the
taxonomy but were close enough the
output is a little bit not user-friendly
at the moment because as I said an
output is really a cloud of points it's
a cloud of hypothetical outputs of your
study now an output of your study is by
itself not a single point so we could
have ten to the six state vectors that
are themselves maybe 10 to the 4 how do
you report that to the user we're not
quite sure so I'm going to very quickly
and show you some big shoes clouds of
points the idea being that in
development we will decide what measures
of variation
important but what to do with them is
pretty straightforward if the variation
is small you are accepted this is a
picture it's comparing three different
ways of imputing data is the one that
has the tightest lines you accept it
that's the one that has the closest bars
to each other that's effective
imputation on classification as its
effect of cheshire invitation message
that's on a very big data set that's a
few gigabytes of data actually leading
to that output effects of missing data
here here is a more realistic experiment
that some people would like to do much
muscle open the future you essentially
ask the user if they like the resulting
variations and the data if the picture
on the upper left corner is acceptable
some they could have ten percent of
their data missing and this is sampled
over data uniform so on this particular
studies they could safely have any ten
percent of their data missing ones as a
handle the picture in the lower right
social role huge variation and other
structure is already obscured so maybe
you don't want search percent of the
data missing I hope that they asked more
questions than I answered because this
was my fully my intention I hope that I
will be able to have some productive
discussion afterwards with people making
your marks about what is missing and
what it needs to be done main points
just in one long sentence interesting it
sets will not ever be made entirely
clean because the recession is unknown
unknown so you think your data is
cleaned up but it's actually damaged but
you could hypothetically examine the
effects of your data being damaged we
suggest developing your hybrid simple
analytic tools it traces consequences or
operations on data to outcome of the
study and allows the user to make
decisions in a more informed manner so
that was my part thank you very much for
patients
so I'll take the last one minute here to
just summarize so the way that that Oleg
and I give this talk is I kind of start
by presenting it in English and then
Oleg presents it in math to prove that
there's some legitimacy to it for the
people who really like the mathematical
side of things and then at the end I try
to bring it back to english that
somebody like a doctor can understand so
I think the the point that we're trying
to make with this is number one we're
really thinking about changing the
fundamental way that we look at a set of
data a set of features uh because it's
really it's not just about looking at
them as a series of measurements or is a
series of points that you can use to
predict or describe something it's about
looking at each one of those as an
approximation with some degree of error
associated with it and intrinsically
that makes sense except data scientists
in general and certainly in healthcare
don't often approach data like that from
the very base level of modeling right
and so this is why I actually hunted up
somebody like Oleg who's got
mathematical experience particularly an
uncertainty quantification because I
think it's important to not just make a
prediction not just build the model but
to trace the consequences of the
uncertainty of each of those variables
throughout the process and I think this
is really our effort to understand that
at the very beginning of the entire
process so that we can say right away
when someone hands you a set of data can
I answer my question from this or not
reasonably and I think that's a very
simple question but it's something that
we don't always have our brain wrapped
around when we're starting a data
science project or a predictive
analytics project and so what we tried
to do is go from that basic question via
a series of you know via a series of
uncertainty quantification steps to come
up with some way that we could say at
the very beginning of a project yes you
can use this no you can't or yes you
could use this with a little bit of a
little bit of a twist on it or a little
bit of cleaning or a little bit of
adjusting and this is our answer to that
so like Oleg said I think we've got it
to the point over the course of the last
year where it's a pretty mature idea and
we have a pretty mature approach to how
we're dealing with it and now we just
have to catch up with the coding and so
it's you know it's not a nicely polished
finished graphical user interface and I
said you know only can we can we make it
look nice can you make a pretty picture
can you turn those clouds into something
three-dimensional and to which by the
answer was you don't know you don't even
understand what we're doing obviously
if you can ask a question like that so
so so the point is it's hard to make a
pretty picture of this but when you
really start to understand the
variability of the data set underneath
it you start to see and start to think
in these kind of clouds and it reminds
me of eight or ten years ago when i was
doing computational biology and genomics
work there were whole families of plots
that were introduced that people looked
at and said what the heck is that but
after looking at them over and over
again they described the uncertainty of
microarray classic of microarray
measurements and such and it became part
of what we do so we're starting to think
like this and we're starting to think
more in probability clouds and less in
discrete points and we're carrying that
thinking all the way through from the
beginning to the end and I think at the
end of the day what that allows us to do
is really understand our data better
from the beginning so that we really
understand when we get an answer how
sure are we that that answers the right
thing to do but also when we get a set
of data how sure are we that we should
be spending our time even using that
data to answer the question and how can
we wrap some numbers around that and how
can we measure that not just sort of
have a gut feeling about it so these are
the kind of fundamental questions that
interest us and this is one way that
we're approaching that and hopefully
next year at this time we'll have
something that at least has some sort of
pretty pictures that we can show you and
and a more robust user interface but in
the meantime we're happy to talk about
anything from the application side of
this to the very detailed computational
side of things and we welcome anybody's
input so thanks and if you've got any
questions we probably get a minute or
two and then and then we can connect
afterwards